et se retrouver à la plage ou encore au
camping après des mois de confinement
notre magazine de l'été nous emmène ce
midi à pouilly-en-auxois son camping
retrouve peu à peu son activité il aura
juste manqué à la fin du printemps un
petit rayon de soleil emmanuel
pinsonneault et romain libre dans le
secteur du tourisme les campings ont
sans doute ont été fortement impactés
par la crise sanitaire ils ont dû
traverser les différentes périodes de
confinement puis les restrictions
sanitaires se sont relâchés mais c'est à
ce moment là que la météo a commencé à
faire des siennes bref une saison bien
difficile pour les campeurs et les
campings on va en parler tout de suite
avec le propriétaire du camping de
pouilly en auxois avec les châteaux aux
alentours vous avez châteauneuf vous
avez commarin après vous avez bonne
bonne qui à main d'une demi heure du jeu
également qu'il ya moins d'une
demi-heure par la voie rapide
vous avez côté morvan aussi avec ce lieu
qui était une demi heure
vous avez semur en auxois aussi qui est
une jolie fille l'apparat ya moins d'une
demi heure
[Musique]
ludovic bonjour bonjour elle a réussi à
chauffer un peu l'avons bien là on est à
26 26 degrés vous étiez déjà là quand
même
au moment d de la troisième de
confinement vous étiez ouvert comment ça
s'est passé
alors oui on est on a fait le choix de
rester ouverts malgré confinement de
notre côté nous on est on est
indépendant ton à notre compte
donc même même si l'activité était très
faible quelques travailleurs quelques
quelques personnes de passage pour le
travail on a fait le choix de rester
ouverts mais on a fait entre 10 et 15%
du chiffre d'affaires habituel sur un
mois d'avril au mois de mai le week-end
de l'ascension et les week-ends cossue
de vie c'était c'était un peu le sourire
donc on a pas mal de gens qui ont
réservé des mobile homes des
emplacements qui se retrouveraient les
familles complètes
certains venant du sud d'autres venant
du nord pour pour se retrouver un
week-end un week-end où quelques jours
quelques jours en plein air donc ça nous
a permis de bien nous préparer de
remettre à jour au niveau du restaurant
les menus voilà
on dérange pas
non pas du tout dites moi vous êtes là
pour combien de temps ah bin là où 120
samedi on était là pour quinze jours
vous venez d'où de la moselle à
montville et c'est quelque chose qui
vous a manqué là pendant cette période
un peu oui oui quand même
quand même parce que c'était long quoi
faut un petit peu sortir ce cette
pandémie de la tête mais bon pas évident
mais autres membres dans les biens on
est bien ça nous a changé les idées on
est tranquille à moi il manque le temps
parce que ça te fera eh oui ici l'été a
commencé avec l'eau de la piscine plus
chaude que les rangs bien un été qui
après tant de frein à l'activité tant
d'incertitudes annonce quand même
quelques signes de reprise comme un gros
bateau qui aurait fait escale il va
falloir un peu de temps pour remettre
les machines en route et pour que
l'activité retrouve sa vitesse de
croisière mais ça se présente plutôt
bien ici par exemple le taux de
réservation pour les mobil-homes cet été
atteint déjà les 98%